rob kardashian is spending quality time
with a new lady yep rob has a new woman
crush Wednesday
Alexis sky but it doesn't come without a
bit of drama so apparently she's feuding
with his ex blac Chyna just days after
Alexis claims Chyna hurled a drink at
her in a private party in LA and
demanded her to leave a VIP section Rob
is making it clear he has the hots for
Alexis on Wednesday Rob took to snapchat
with a pic of the love and hip-hop star
caption my WCW I've been wanting you for
so long well it looks like the wait will
soon be over he's hanging out with
Alexis they spent the night whipping up
a homemade dinner together so we have
chicken breasts after sharing snaps of
their dishes
Alexis posted a cryptic interest story
that read I want to be with someone that
brings the angel out of me forever not
the devil and he will be my husband when
I was younger I would always date an
older guy but it's a problem of me
dating now is because I still want that
validation of that love I've never got
for my dad okay so for everyone who does
not know who alexis is she is a 24 year
old model and reality star known for
Love & Hip Hop Hollywood and Love & Hip
Hop New York she is Fetty WAPs ex and
baby mama they share a one-year-old
daughter together and she's also been
really open about her co-parenting
challenges with the rapper of course it
sounds like something Rob is familiar
with dealing with his on-and-off-again
legal battles with blac Chyna you know
he's also a father of a two-year-old
dream who was too adorable so it seems
like they have a lot in common
and apparently Rob and Alexis also have
history so check this out after one user
claimed Rob had not learned his lesson
from his last relationship
adding Alexis just doing all this
despite China grow up Rob he came to her
defense tweeting me and Alexis known
each other for five years so stop that
Rob sisters Kim Khloe and Kourtney were
on watch what happens live while the
date was going down and while they
didn't address Alexis they did share
some updates on their brother
and his baby mama take a look how is Rob
doing he's very good yeah good yeah he's
great
okay I don't see him on the show much at
all a little bit more on the next season
he he has a smooth like sometimes he's
like look I didn't sign up for this and
then sometimes he's like I'm cool to do
it all the Kardashians versus blac Chyna
where do you guys stand with blac Chyna
today
still in a lawsuit I thought that
lawsuit had been I thought hers had been
tossed out you know I honestly don't we
don't know you don't care you can't keep
up yeah that's one thing that the
Kardashians can't keep up on all right
so to keep up with Rob and his new crush
be sure to subscribe to all things et
and until next time I'm at Kourtney
underscore teza know bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]